In this second season, figuring out the end of the series,
that was a big thing this year.
And I can feel where we are and the GPS inside me
is telling me, we're here on the road to the end.
Mr. Turner, may I come inside?
Who are you?
Aunt Josephine.
When something happens in the cult
and they can't handle somebody, when
someone goes rogue and leaves the cult, Aunt Josephine comes.
[SCARY MUSIC]
I need to see Leanne.
She's in desperate need of my help.
She comes in when everything goes wrong.
She's the cleaner and once you meet Aunt Josephine,
that's usually the end.
[CRASH]
It's interesting how you have a Leanne that's
going to be unapologetic, and say,
I'm no longer going to listen to rules,
I'm going to do what I want to do.
And she's saying, I want to be a part of this family.
And there's really no way you can get me out of this family.
Vanity is a sin, Aunt Josephine.
You're learning what the show is about,
and I think by the end of the season here,
we wanted you to feel like, wow, this family just made
a deal with somebody that they should be afraid of.
I can feel a dark thing in me getting bigger.